حضرتكن دبلوماسيين شهدته العاصمه
الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا على مدى ايام اخره
زياره وزيارتي الخارجيه الفرنسيه
والالمانيه بحثت الوزيرتان مع المسؤولين
الاثيوبيين سبل دعم الحكومه في تنفيذ بنود
اتفاقيه السلام المبرمه مع جبهه التراي
خاصه مسائي اعاده الاعمار ودعم المتضررين
من الحرب وعره الوزيرتان في مؤتمر صحفي
مشترك مع وزير الخارجيه الاثيوبي تجربه
بلديهما الذين حقق المصالح حتى بعد سنوات
من الحرب
نحن هنا ممثلون عن الاتحاد الاوروبي ولقد
سمعنا في العامين الماضيين اخبارا مروعه
من اثيوبيا عن اراقه الدماء ومئات القتلى
اثيوبيا شرعت في طريق السلام بدعم من
الاتحاد الافريقي ونحن هنا لنشجعكم على
مواصله السير على هذا الطريق
بريتوريا وانا مدريكه للشجاعه التي يجب ان
تتحلى بها الحكومه لاختيار السلام وهذا ما
فعله بلدانا ونود ان تفعله اثيوبيا
دبلوماسيون في اديس ابابا يترجم اهتماما
اوروبيا ودوليا باتفاقيه السلام خصوصا مع
قطع الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبهه اشواطا كبيره
في مسار تنفيذي بنود الاتفاقيه ومن ابرزه
تسليم الاسلحه الثقيله
وتسلم الجيش الاثيوبي الدفعه الاولى من
الاسلحه الثقيله التي كانت بحوزه جبهه
تكراي تنفيذ الاتفاقيه السلام فيما اكد
منسق الجيش الاثيوبي ان العمليه تم دون
عقبات
الحكومه والشعب يريدان السلامه والتنميه
والجيش الوطني سيعمل من اجل سياده البلاد
وحمايه اراضيها وهو وفقا الاتفاقيه السلام
موجود في مناطقه الدفاعيه وقد تسلم
الاسلحه الثقيله من جبهه الذكريات بطريقه
سلميه وهادئه فيما اعتبر الاتحاد الافريقي
الذي اشرف على عمليه التسليم الاجراء خطوه
مهمه لاستعاده النظام وضمان الامن
والسلامه في اثيوبيا مناسبا جميع الاطراف
المضيء قدما في هذه العمليه حسن الرزاق
الجزيره اديس ابابا